très grande fierté on remercie le
département d'avoir pensé à notre beau
village et on attend avec impatience
ceci mars pour pouvoir accueillir cette
deuxième étape de Paris Nice
[Musique]
ça va se passer dans le centre
centre-ville donc on a déjà pensé à tout
ce qui était ramassage scolaire pour
pouvoir mettre en place des déviations
mettre des parkings pour que les gens du
centre village puissent le dimanche soir
mettre leur voiture à l'extérieur pour
pas qu'il soit gêné pour aller au
travail et on est en train de prévoir
des petites animations le dimanche avec
un petit parcours vélo et un petit
parcours VTT
[Musique]
moi pas du tout je suis rugbyman par
contre j'ai pierre Ferranti et
Jean-Louis bouissé qui sont des fervent
cyclistes qui sont tous les deux des
élus et qui sont très très contents de
pouvoir accueillir Parisis moi je suis
très content mais eux en plus quand ils
sont comme des enfants avec justement
les les beaux vélos qu'on a vu
[Musique]